this week we're talking about task
queues big data and stackdriver welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news just recently
launched for everyone
cloud task is a fully managed service
backed by App Engine you can easily
create new queues and offload any
asynchronous tasks giving you a
distributed task queue that you can
integrate with any of your apps with
built-in scheduling and deduplication as
well as an easy to integrate API cloud
tasks can be a great way to simplify
your architecture and focus on what
matters the users using your application
check out the details and get started
with a QuickStart guide all you need is
a GCP project with App Engine you may
already keep up to date with news about
Apache Hadoop and spark but cloud data
proc has lots of new features to try out
data proc is Google's fully managed to
dupe and spark service and has added
tons of integrations and features to
help you build Big Data solutions this
includes support for new versions of
software like Ubuntu and flink easy to
add components such as Jupiter and
Zeppelin and lots of Google Cloud
integrations like bigquery the full
details are in the blog post as well as
some links for you to try out data proc
for yourself but no matter where your
app runs you likely need to know how
it's running well that's one thing
stackdriver can help with Charles Baer a
Google cloud solution architect recently
published a blog post on how to build
your application and monitor for long
term metric analysis making it easier to
spot trends that you may not see from
reviewing short time frames
we've got the high level considerations
and an in-depth solution guide with a
reference implementation so you can
start to see the big picture and if you
want to learn a bit more about
stackdriver itself I definitely
recommend checking out the stack driver
sandbox it's an open source set of tools
that make it easy to get started and
learn what stack driver can do you can
clone the repo and simply run a script
to set up a full demo environment
including a micro services based demo
application and traffic generator giving
you the benefit of working in a real
scenario without disrupting your
production environment this is a great
way to learn more and practice how you
might do some sre tasks in Google Cloud
so don't delay and try it out if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link have any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you